تحت ضغطي لاحتجاجات في ايران المدعي العام
يعلن الغاء شرطه الاداب في محاوله للتهدئه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يبدا غدا تنفيذ تحديد
سعر سقف الغاز الروسي وموسكوت يحذر وزنسكي
لا يراه جديا
وفرنسا تواجه بولندا وانجلترا تقابل
السنغال في دور السته عشر من منافسات كاس
العالم
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
حتى الان في اخمادها اعلن المدعي العام
الايراني
وكانت هذه القوه البوليسيه احد اهم اسباب
التظاهرات التي اندلعت في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي بعد مقتل الفتاه الكرديه
مساء من البالغه من العمر 22 عاما خلال
احتجازه من قبل وحده تابعه لما يسمى
بشرطته الادب
هذا وقد اضر من المحتجون ليله الماضيه
النار في مقر البسيج بعدد من المحافظات
والمدن الايرانيه
كما هاجم محتجون بالمولوتوف مكتبه امام
الجمعه في مدينه قدشان بمحافظه خرسان فيما
اضرم اخرون النار في اعلانات حكوميه في
يزدره
وزاره وزاره
[موسيقى]
التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني كشفت عن
اعتقال 115 من القوات الايرانيه لدعمهم
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد واضاف
تلفزيون لان العسكريين يمثلون واحد في
المئه من عدد المحتجزين في الاحتجاجات
التي تشهدها ايران منذ قرابه ثلاثه اشهر
في تضارب انديه حصيله قتل الاحتجاجات في
ايران اعلن مجلس الامن القومي الايراني عن
مقتل اكثر من 200 شخص خلال الاحتجاجات في
البلاد بينما اعلن الحرس ثوري الايراني ان
عدد القتلى اكثر من 300 شخص امام منظمه
حقوق الانسان الايرانيه فقد اكدت ان
الحصيله وصلت انه الى نحو 500 شخص بينهم
اطفال ونساء
قمع النظام الايراني للمحتجين وكاله ميزان
التابعه للقضاء تتحدث عن اكثر من 100 قتيل
وقبلها اقل قيادي في الحرس الثوري بمقتل
اكثر من 300 اغلبه في كردستان ايراني
الارقام الرسميه الايرانيه تضم قتل في
صفوف الامن في محاوله لتبرير استخدام
القوه ضد المتظاهرين حسب المعارضات
الايرانيه مهما يكون امر حصيله قتل
الاحتجاجات حسب منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ومقارها اوزلو تتحدث عن قرابه
500 قتيل في صفوف المحتاجين بينهم نساء
واطفال
ايرانيون يقللون من شان الارقام السابقه
المعلنه ويتحدثون عن حصيله اكبر للضحايا
والمعتقلين والمفقودين جراء استخدام الامن
الايراني
البحث عنهم من قبل عائلتهم بالالف
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران هي الاطول
والاكثر دمويه لاستخدام النظام القوه
لفضها ماذا فعل دول الغربيه للتحرك لفرد
عقوبات اضافيه على ايران بسبب عمليات
القتل الجماعي للشعب الايراني كما وصفتها
دول الغربيه
والتلفزيونيه وقفت بعدما تم تفتيش منزلها
وكان نظام الايرانيه اوقف الاشخاص على
خلفيه الاحتجاجات بينهم فنانون كبار
وسياسيونها ورياضيوننا
كشفت البحريه الامريكيه عن اعتراضها سفينه
في خليجي عمان كانت تهرب اكثر من 50 طنا
من الاسلحه ووقود الصواريخ وكانتو ابحر في
خط بحريا من ايران الى اليمن وقال الاسطول
الخامس الامريكي في بياناتنا هذه العمليه
هي الثانيه لمصادره شحنه كبيره من الاسلحه
المهربه في غضون الشهر وقد كذا قائد
الاصول الخامس
ان اعتراض السفياني يظهر بوضوح استمرار
نقل ايران غير القانوني للمساعدات الفتاكه
وسلوكها المزعزع للاستقرار واشهدت كوبر
على ان تصدير المباشر وغير المباشر
للاسلحه او بيعها او نقلها الى الحوثيين
في اليمن ينتهي كل القانون الدولي وقرار
مجلس الامن الصله
وكان الاصول الخامس في البحريه الامريكيه
قد اعلن في منتصف الشهر الماضي اعتراضه
لسفينه الصيد كانت تهرب كميه ضخمه من
المواد المتفجره اثناء عبورها من ايران
عبر خليج عمان في طريقها لميشيات الحسين
وذكر الاسطول الخامس حينها ان القوه
الامريكيه عثرت على اكثر من 70 طن من
كلورات الامونيوم والتي تستخدم عاده في
صناعه وقود الصواريخ وكذلك المتفجره
قال وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر الارياني ان
استهداف جماعه الحوثي لمسجد في محافظه
الحديده بطائره مسيره اثناء صلاه الجمعه
هي جريمه حرب مكتمله الاركان واضاف
الارياني على تويترنا الهجوم اسفر عن مقتل
مدنيين اثنين واصابه خمسه اخرين بينهم
اطفال واكدنا الهجوم الاخير يضاف الى
سلسله الجرائم التي ارتكبتها جماعه الحوثي
ويضافوا الى استهدافها المنهج للاحياء
السكنيه والمنازل والمساجد والاسواق
العامه بهدف الايقاع باكبر قدر من الضحايا
بين المدنيين في ظل صمت دوليا غير مفهوم
وافق على الاتحاد الاوروبيه رسميا على
وضعي حد اقصى عربيه
دولارا للبرميل على ان يبدا تنفيذ القرار
غدا الاثنين وقد قلى الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بيان من القرارات سيخفض بشكل كبير
العائدات التي تجنيها روسيه من النفط بعد
ان شنت حربها على اوكرانيا
وضع السقف لسعر النفط الروسي ليس قرارا
جديا
من جهتي اكدت روسيا رفضها تحديدا سقفا
لسعر النفط غدات اتفاقيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعه السبع واستراليا على اليه من
شانها الحد من واردات موسكو لتمويل
الهجومها على اوكرانيا واقل الناطق باسم
الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتري بيسكوث في موسكو
او قال ان موسكو لن تقبل بتحديد سقفا لسعر
نفطها مؤكدا لاستعداد المسبق لهذا القرار
الهدف المعلن لقرار وضع حد اقصى للسعر
بايعا نفط الروسي ضعف موسكو وحرمانها من
وسائل الاستمرار تمويل عمليتها العسكريه
في اوكرانيا ومن معقل اتخاذ القرارات
العقربيه ضد موسكو جاء الرد الروسي برفض
اعاده صياغه المبادئ الاساسيه للاسواق
الحره وتحذير من فرد اي سقف على صادرات اي
دوله لاسباب سياسيه واتهام الغرب بتهوره
في علاج المشاكل التي اثارها بنفسه كما
اعلنت موسكو بان الطلب على نفسها سيستمر
رغم القرار الغربي قرار تحديد سقف لسعر
النفط الروسي يتزمن مع دخوله حذر على
والده الروسيه عبر البحر اعتبارا من
الاثنين رئيسه المفاوضات الاوروبيه اعتبرت
ان الايرادات النفطات الروسيه ستقلص
واسعار طاقه العالميه ستستقر لكنها رئيس
مركز تطوير طاقه الروسيه لديه نظره
المعاكسه حين اكد ان بلاده لن تابع نفطها
سقف اسعار التكتل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
اقللت من التبعات السلبيه للقرار الاوروبي
حيث اعتبرت انه مازال بامكاني موسكو
جينيار ارباح كبيره بينما اعلنت اليابان
انها تتوقع اجراءات عقبيه من قبل روسيا
بعد القرار الغربي توقعات الخبريه ان تغير
روسيا مسار ضخ النفط نحو الشرق خصوصا
الصين والهند ليبقى التحدي امام الغرب
تعويض حصه روسيا من النفط الامر الذي
سيدخل العالم بازمه نفطن تضاف للغاز على
حد قولهم حنان المصري العربيه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض قليل
في القاهره انطلاق اعمال الندوه المستديره
لمسانده اليمن بشراكه سعوديه مصريه
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار كاس العالم
تواجه فرنسا اليوم بولندا فيما تقابله
انجلترا منتخب السنغال في الدوري 16 كانت
الارجنتين تجاوزت امس واستراليا بهدفين
لهدف ضريبه الموعدا مع هولندا الفائز على
المنتخب الامريكي بثلاثه اهداف لهدف
[موسيقى]
تحيه رياضيه اهلا بكم الى مجاز رياضيه
خلال مباراه الالفي مسيرته الكرويه
ربع نهائي البطوله على حساب استراليا ضارب
الموعد مع هولندا في الدوره ربع النهائي
ماشي يفتتح النتيجه لمنتخب التانغو في
الدقيقه الخامسه والثلاثين مسجلا هدفه
الاول مع بلاده في الدوري خروج المغلوب
خلال مشاركته الخامس في البطوله قبل ان
ياتي الدور في الدقيقه 57 على زميلي ونجم
مانشستر سيتي
في الدقيقه السابعه والسبعين من تقيس
النتيجه عبر الانترنت
[تصفيق]
المنتخب الهولنديه دوره 16 بنجاح الى ربع
نهائي بعد فوزه على نظيره الامريكيه
بثلاثه اهداف لهدف صنع اول هدفين وسجل
ثلاثه الهدف الثالث الحاسم لياقوده لندن
لفوز امام الكثير من ارب اكثر من 44000
متفرج الطواحين افتتحوا التسجيل في اول
عشر دقائق باقدم نفس ديفايد وقبل نهايه
الشوط الاول اضافه هدفه هنا الثاني بنفس
السيناريو عبر داني بليند ونجح المنتخب
الامريكي في تقريص الفرق عبر البديل حجي
رايت في الدقيقه السادسه والسبعين لكن بعد
خمس دقائق حسب ما تنزل دومبريس الامور
وعزوز النتيجه بهدف الثالث في الدقيقه
الحاديه والثمانين ستلعب هولندا التي فازت
امام اكثر من 40 44000 متفرج في دوري
ثمانيه مع الارجنتين
[تصفيق]
وتسعه فرنسا الى استعاده فريقها ومواصله
حمله الدفاع عن لقبها عندما تراقب ولند
الطامحه لتركيب بصمه في هذا المنطقه
فرنسا حامله اللقب بدات مونديال قطر وهي
تخشى تكرار سيناريو 2002 والخروج من دوري
المجموعات
الديوك هو قبل صافره البدايه تلقب ضربه
موجعه بغياب صاحب الكره الذهبيه كريم
بنزيما للاصابه المباراه الافتتاح امام
استراليا قالب فيها الناتج الفرنسيون
للفوز برباعيه
مره اخرى احد ركائز المنتخب يغادر المعسكر
الاصابه وهو لوكاسيرنانديز اللقاء الثاني
امام الدنمارك شهيده فوز الازرق بثنائيتك
ليان بطه مواجهه تونس في الجوله الاخيره
اراها في هذا الشان اهم الركائز يتلقى
المنتخب الفرنسي الخساره بهدف وهبي
في مجموعه تضم الارجنتين والسعودي
والمكسيك اربعه نقاط فقط جعل الزملاء
ليفاندوفسكي يجتازون المجموعه كواصيف
للمنتخب
لقاء واحد جمع البولنديين والفرنسيين في
مسابقه الدوليه وكان ذلك في كاس العالم 82
في اسبانيا لحساب مباراه تحديد المركز
الثالث والذي شهد تفوق النسور بثلاثه
اهداف على زملائي
في المباراه الثانيه ستلعب انجلترا مع
السنغال في دور 16 على ستاد البيت في
الخوف الانجليزي
عن مهدي كره القدم منذ 56 عاما
قبل بدايه البطوله واستمرت الى قبل مواجهه
ثمن النهائي وهو الرجل الذي قاد انجلترا
الى نصف نهائي البطوله الماضيه ونهاء
النسخه الماضيه من كاس اوروبا
اما المهاجم وراجفور فيبدو انه استعاده
ثقته بنفسه مع المنتخب بعد ان كان احد
اللاعبين الثلاثه الذين اضعوا ركله
ترجيحيه امام ايطاليا في نهائي اليورو
اصبح احد المفاتيح المهمه في خط الهجوم
الانجليزيه
السنغال بطل افريقيا تمكن من تخطي دور
المجموعات للمره الثانيه خلال ثلاث
مشاركات له فقط مدربه اليوسي سي عرف كيف
يستغل قدرات لاعبيه الذين ينشطون في اقوى
وابرز الفرق الاوروبيه المدرب السنغالي
يسعى لمعادله افضل انجازا للكره
السينغاليه في المونديال بالوصول الى ربع
النهائي وهو كان احد اعمده المنتخب كما ان
التجديد عقده قبل ايام من انطلاق المنافسه
ساعد السيسي في التركيز بشكل افضل على
تقديم اداء جيد خلال المباريات فهل تثبت
اسود التينجا بان المنتخب الافريقيه باتت
رقما صعبا في البطوله اما ان واقعيه
الانجليز ستنهي المغامره السنغاليه
[موسيقى]
منذ المباراه الاولى قدم اغويرو الرد
الافضل على كل ما مر به لقد قدم اداء
مذهلا في المباريات الثلاث التي خاضها حتى
الان وعلينا مواصله البناء لعبت الى جواره
في العديد من المباريات الدوليه وعشنا معا
العديد من اللحظات ولا يستحق ما مر به مع
ناديه
المهمه يوم الجمعه
والارشادات اللازمه وما علينا القيام به
ناموا ان يكون متواجدا في الملعب يوم
المباراه وان يقود الفريق من ارض الملعب
هدفنا هو الصعود وانا متاكد ان اللاعبين
سيكون جاهزين ومستعدين ستكون مواجهه صعبه
لكن علينا ان نحافظ على الهدوء
منتخب السنبا بعد مباراه الخشنه امام
الكاميرون خرج بي اصابتين هما المهاجم
غابريجيسوس والمدافع اليكس تالاس كلفتما
توديع البطوله مثل ما اكده السبت المسؤول
الاعلامي للاتحاد البرازيلي جاسوس شعره في
مباراه بالام دفعت المدرب الى استبداله
واخر تقارير تفيد الى حاجته لشهر للتعافي
بينما يحتاج الكستليس لعمليه جراحيه بعد
ما ترك الملعب مصابا وهو يبكي اثر اصطدامه
باحد لاعبي الكاميرون تتضمن قائمه
المصابين المنتخب البرازيلي كل من الظهير
الايمن دانيلو وظهير الايسر اليكس ساندرو
ونجم الفريق نيمار
كان هذه ابرز اخبار المدير شكرا لمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
تحياتي
افاده مراسله العربيه بان اسرائيل شنت فجر
اليوم قاره على مواقع التابعه للفصائل
الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه موضحا ان الغارات
استهدفت موقع القادسيه التابعه لحركات
حماس غرب مدينه خانيونس بالاضافه الى
مواقع اخرى في رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه كما تم
اطلاق صاروخين على الاقل من القطاع اتجاه
المستوطنات الحدود
حتى المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا عبد الله
باتيلي جميع المؤسسات الليبيه على الدخول
في حوار سعيا لايجاد حل الى الاجتماع
المتوسطه دون ان تذكر تفاصيل عنه الجماعه
اشعل ايلون ماسك مالك وشركه تويتر
برسائل البريد الالكتروني
[موسيقى]
اقامه مركز البحر الاحمر للدراسات
السياسيه والامنيه مائده مستديره لمناقشه
اوراق البحثيه حول الدور الدعم لليمن من
قبل كل من السعوديه ومصر توصيه الحاضرين
تمحورت حول اهميه وقف القتال وازاله
الالغام وبعضهم ذهب الى استخدام الطاقه
كورك ورقه ضغط لفرد اليمن على اولويات
الاجنه الدوليه
خبره رفيعه مستوى اجتمعت في القاهره
لمناقشه شركه السعوديه المصريه لحمايه
الامن القوميه العربيه اليمن نموذج والتي
ناقشت عدد من الاوراق البحثيه الهامه في
هذا الشان منها ما كان معنيا بالتدخلات
الخارجيه وحمايه الوطن العربيه منها
تهديدات ايرانيه في اليمن لكل المنطقه
العربيه وبالذات السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الصين في الموضوع
نسرين ليها وضع كبير الندوه استهدفت في
واحده من اوراقها اهميه مشروع مسام لازاله
الالغام ولكن هذا الموضوع عرج بالحديث على
عدد من الالغام الاكثر اهميه من وجهه نظر
المشاركين
امريكا وبين ايران بس الواحد لما يتامل
المساله بعمق جدا يجب انه تم دعم للايه
للجهود الايرانيه في تفكيك المنطقه عمليه
التفكيك هذه احنا لابد ان احنا ننظر اليه
على انها انغام بتزرع في جسد العروبه
التوصيات وتمورك حول ضروره استخدام اوراق
الضغط العربيه لوضع اليمن على راسها
الاولويات الدوليه
النيه عندها اوراق ضغط حقيقيه
متخصصه من القوات المسلحه المصريه
والسعوديه
لرفع الالغام في المناطق التي يتفق عليها
تحت مظله الجامعه العربيه
وتختر كل الاطراف المعنيه بانها مستعده
للبدل فورا في رفع هذه
ضروره انهاء القتال اولا قبل الحديث عن
ازاله الالغام والا سيكون امرا لا ينتهي
تامر نصره العربيه القاهره
خرزه نحو خمسه الاف في عامل في كوريا
الجنوبيه في مسيره داعمه لاضراب السائقي
الشاحنات عن العمل وذلك احتجاجا على سياسه
العمل والتي تسببت بدورها في تعطيل سلاسل
التوريده
الى العناوين
تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات في ايران المدعي العام
يعلن الغاء شرطه الاداب في محاوله التهدئه
الاتحاد الاوروبيه
لا يراه جديا
فرنسا تواجه بولندا وانجلترا تقابله
السنغال في دوري 16 من منافسات كاس العالم
[موسيقى]